fait le calcul mais je les ai là à les
chiffres chez vous à 100 millions le
ratio est beaucoup plus faible pour
l'instant en had que chez nous en france
alors alors justement alors justement
ludovic toro en fait en fait j'ai eu
peur ouais pourquoi que tu mettes m
division en face de moi tu vas dire face
à face n'était pas possible non face à
laurent sa pose aucun problème parce que
j'ai passé mon après midi à revoir les
vidéos quand il a parlé mais là rien
d'extraordinaire
il a deux axes le premier c'est normal
ça tombe autant il est passé là bas
c'était donc la première chose il faut
sauver tout le monde dans les hôpitaux
et bien sur wii et la raison et les
autres faut qu'il vive
oui il a raison après je me tenir après
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il dit bah
c'est vrai que ça fait des années que
les hôpitaux ce qu'à sa gueule n'est pas
seulement les hôpitaux toutes les
médecines dans notre pays d'accord et
donc on paye ça aujourd'hui c'est
surtout ce qui me gêne c'est que le
gouvernement les gouvernements pas
seulement au gouvernement français nous
montre du doigt comme c'était nous mais
responsable mais depuis alors que ce
sont eux les restaurants tu as réseau
depuis le début on a accusé la
population depuis le début les jeunes
les moins jeunes les vieux c'est eux qui
sont les coupables
ap les décideurs c'est pas nous bien
éviter absolument voilà autre chose que
tu as 10 par rapport à monsieur verhoek
nous a raconté des bobs là dessus je
peux que t'accompagner dire que les
jeunes était évident qu'ils sont
contagion ils sont pas plus mort que ça
ce qu'il faut dire et là je crois que tu
a raison de le dire il ya à peu près 400
milles kovy de long c'est à dire que là
on compte que les morts il ya les
combinons et chaussures que c'est une
pathologie qui est très loin et au delà
de ça n'oubliez pas une chose tous les
gens qu'on n'a pas pris en compte dans
les services hospitaliers
depuis un an vont avoir des maladies
mais les vals ali beaucoup plus avancé
parce qu'on aura tant le temps les
traiter donc ça sera les parler les
autres malades aiguilles et qu'on a pas
bien joué dans la saison mais on essaye
pour ça enfin les voilà oui c'est ça
aussi il est pas du tout comploter
similaire d'uriné et ils disent que je
pense moi aussi moi j'étais très dans le
genre faut aller vite faut fermer va
jouer chez vacciner ouais et j'encourage
duléry bien sûr elles font et c'est ça
qui est tout à fait donc le problème
c'est que ça a duré trop longtemps il ya
eu trop d'erreurs
il ya eu des problèmes de communication
et c'est vrai tu l'as dit les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas en notre
faveur
parce qu'au niveau européen on va être
bientôt le deuxième pays où il ya le
plus de morts excuse moi de vos dessins
au bout de trois confinement c'est pas
terrible ce côté quand vous me disiez
les feuilles les papiers à remplir
sérieusement on marche la tête et repas
à picorer vous y faire ça en plus sur
les changer tous les jours il y avait
dix pages amp
c'est pas comme ça qu'on traite les gens
gilles verdez de trouver comprenant
moins
honnêtement vous m'avez choqué sur la
copie parce que je trouve que parfois
vous avez un
alors il est choqué très facile je sais
que je connais je peux d'individus je
fais mes presse car la ville est fiché
c'est vrai je te dis la dernière fois
que j'avais pas fais mes lacets il était
choqué pourtant les exprimé presque avec
désinvolture
si on n'avait pas agi nous aurions une
hécatombe
alors oui on a fait des erreurs oui mais
un trajet sans de dos on le brésil et
dont vous on a déjà pardon végète
huttérites que vous on a déjà une
hécatombe à son nom mais ça a été bien
pire
mais et que vous deviez certain qu'on en
aurait eu beaucoup plus que ça pardon à
chaque fois je sais qu'on ressort cet
exemple là à chaque fois je sais qu'on
ne contredit mais ya maintenant des
études bien plus sérieuses qui ont été
faites des suédois ont moins confiné et
ont été beaucoup plus souple que nous et
non pas un ratio de rh vous dis oui mais
certains y ont peut pas le comparer aux
autres pays ont des regards d audace au
danemark ailleurs sauf que justement la
suède est le pays qui ressemble plus aux
autres pays d'europe par rapport au
danemark à la finlande et aux autres
pays donc franchement rien y avait
d'autres solutions que celle là je vous
jure